[Music]
he obviously like the pictures that's
supermodel Gigi Hadid playing coy about
her boyfriend Zayn Malik's reaction to
her super sexy spread in the 2016 Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Issue ET spoke with
the 20 year old at the magazine's party
Tuesday night in New York City where she
adorably opened up about her bow and her
bestie it was the first person you
called and you saw that picture I texted
my special someone I just I always get
excited so you texted your special
someone and I'm happy with T for that
for you how could you not look at her I
think yeah but also my mom strong
girlfriends they're kind of taking over
the world it's a really do cool thing
you're not that like my friends are
killing it Lilly and I met this is both
of our third year doing Sports
Illustrated so swim week every year's
our anniversary this is our three year
friendship anniversary
and then last question I mean obviously
Taylor was such big news she killed it
last night with her speech and stuff how
proud of you are for you I mean I was
expecting it I'm not going to lie I was
not surprised that she won but we're so
proud of her and I think it's just a
really great ending to the journey of
1989 and no one deserves it more than
her she's the most hard-working
business-minded brilliant kind person
and I'm so happy here I wish I could
have been there but we are all there in
spirit